what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here to watch
Visions episode four five and six if you
wanna watch one two and three that is on
a separate video of course joined by
Star Wars expert Michael Tessler
followed him on social media use the
force to leave a like you know what to
do and as always full length scratch and
watch how long's reducing up with your
own copy available for a super sexy
rejects that are a patreon hey thank you
all who have joined us so far but guys
our Star Wars Visions reactions are
sponsored by a sponsor that I freaking
love get out of the way for a little bit
Michael thank you again to me underneath
for sponsoring this video guys I'm in a
onesie I've never owned a onesie and my
epidermis has never felt more
comfortable nay I need a better word
than comfortable I feel
as snug as a bug in a rug I obviously
love their clothing I went to the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 premiere
and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon
lounge pants that people would not stop
talking about it easily the most
comfortable one there at the event now I
am entering further into the galaxy far
far away you might say with this limited
edition print of AKA baby Yoda is the
child himself grogu has traveled across
the Galaxy and into our hearts and now
you can meditate with him and
galactically soft undies socks bralettes
loungewear and more available in sizes
extra small to 4XL like I said the new
Star Wars Prince is limited so grab this
bounty now before it's all gone they
also gave me their shorts which again is
so soft and perfect fitting too even my
wife loves to wear them speaking of my
wife I even got this bralette for her
too I said take it off I'm showing it in
the video Woman she'd love seeing me in
this underwear my Jedi Mind Tricks to
keep her attracted to me don't work but
this underwear is doing at the job
wearing it right now I've never been
more relaxed on camera sitting has just
generally never felt so soothing but yes
rejection the hype is real do not
impressed with me on these your first
pair is on the house Seth is a promise
so to get 25 off your first order and
free standard shipping go to mionys.com
rejects once again that is mionys.com
Rejects and May the force be with you
always I hope they partner up with us
again because
yes
[Music]
this is your final call whoa Wallace and
grommet
City Light Academy it's our annual
celebration of our pilot trainees and
their families believe it or not
[Laughter]
[Music]
an actual Star Wars character this is
canon
[Music]
that's racist Craig
also Harris undul
still racist R2 oh look at that Astra
Mac
I am your mother
boiling
a slinky the dog this is red leader
oh that's the planet they're from I made
lunch right
[Music]
Harris and Doula is on the poster
her name's Annie thoroughly
you forgot your lunch
City flight Academy's annual race day be
sure to check out the official wedge
themed products
I love this idea that wedge
Milwaukee
flying porta potty I hate you
space tug actually that's it someone has
to do the basic maintenance
they have that exact balloon at Disney
World do they yeah
[Music]
oh my that's inappropriate
oh it's their home
oh mother
oh no silly Billy can you come back
later clean up will be after the race oh
Annie can you get your Porta-Potty off
the starting line thank you eh don't
worry we're leaving
[Music]
pissed off the wrong Mom let's get
strapped in why are we strapping in we
aren't just moving the ship aren't we go
nope always wear a seat belts
family race is on
please
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh no
[Music]
one in these days oh you can't say that
junk is embarrassing said one barely
functioning is embarrassing you are
embarrassing no
is that how you really feel yeah
Julian mommy's waiting do it oh
be anytime I play Battlefront 2.
is that one activate the stabilizers
get the controls
I can't find this
her mom falls out dies it's all her
fault
[Music]
yeah Voice work is so consistent
ah yes
who needs parents when you can win the
race
this is really cute hold on red leader
he's about to get bumpy and yet another
win for the van repos
oh this junkyard racing Vibe that's so
much fun
[Music]
place is last place no
[Laughter]
extraordinary
[Music]
Holy balls
watch them be last we have
Ubuntu Eve
I've learned a lot from you exactly
I should have told you about the race
even if you can be a little bit
embarrassing of course I'm embarrassing
I am your mother I am your mother
I'm your father
ah well that was cute yeah that was a
nice uh a nice break from the serious
stuff I know she learned to use the
force at the end that's what happened
that's what that's how these all go
right here they all you learn to use the
forks yeah no that was great uh just
another cute mother-daughter story
filled with a bunch of cute little
Easter eggs throughout
uh I'm not my admittedly not my favorite
of the four we've seen so far this was
my favorite I made it yeah but it was
really fun and I think at the end of the
day that's the whole point the whole
point is to have the variety and just
have something that is just super
adorable here like they're so family
friendly and I think I think the other
prior three are not like super family
friendly uh they're they're so much more
mature in the way they're executed but
to have that kind of break a little bit
of that like British wit to it uh I
thought was awesome and I mean the
animation still is like Vivid and
colorful as you'd want I've never seen
Wallace and Gromit I've seen chicken I
saw a chicken run when I was like my
movie stresses man seven so I don't
remember chicken run at all
um that'd be fun I actually react to
that on this channel I've seen it before
it might be fun to react to that uh but
yeah I thought that was still a really
adorable piece that they had right there
yeah a little hey Greg yeah I want to
watch the next one okay he's just trying
to shorten and sort of the talk are you
I want to watch the next one all right
we'll watch the next one I want to hear
about you never run there were Easter
eggs Michael come on I did so good with
the Easter eggs the Easter eggs I was I
was bored I was Harrison Doula I saw
them all I got them all yeah you did
yeah sneaky guy oh his next one's long
let's see what's going on
[Music]
that's so pretty is that dust or water
looks like water yeah yes
can confirm
that's gorgeous yeah right
that's whence every time
read better
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
why are the seventh Envision so cool
yikes
where's this Weaponry I think it's a
biological part of them like a
Tails
[Music]
this guy's like all for one for my hero
Academia
I like that he branded him oh
yeah
I don't think tell us the one for the
job
I was gonna say I feel like he's going
through some things right now
honey
all their paths at the dark side so
anger usually stems from Fear hello
there
that's humiliated
nowhere
[Music]
this guy looks just like Hunter from Owl
House and your fans will know what I'm
talking about
oh damn
this mission was meant for him to
confront this guy
oh I'm ready to make you a Sith I'll
start by killing you
God I love this POV
no
ship looks like kylo's
ah yes on the way to bang sing say
foreign
too much anger bud
for real we've been the palm of the hand
lifting you up
foreign
what's the plan here
ah cool America
all right
oh cool
fiber crystals oh that's really cool
uh
what
they both found balance yeah same
Christmas
you need the balance
she's gonna help me
she represents the balance
oh oh I just got chilled that's cool
to face your Darkness
off off with your head
is that Jonathan majors in the statue
the dance with Tat's ass music
jet pack jet pack
parachute parachute
[Music]
no oh it's time for him
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
we got ourselves the anime episode that
was gorgeous it was great
I love the tone of it overall as well
um Michael why don't you talk while I
fix this little thing on screen really
fast
no I thought it was uh I mean it's just
like a friendly reminder of Star Wars s
Universe fits so well into the anime
genre anime particularly for some of the
more ancient stories it really really
works and I'm surprised they don't just
make a show about something from a long
time ago that doesn't necessarily affect
the rest of Canon this is beautiful I
mean I think uh I will say I'm just a
little tired of like
the balance yeah yeah it's becoming a
little bit too reoccurring here
especially envisions like I'm like did
you guys consult with each other about
the repetition of some of the stories I
don't think that they did yeah I like
the idea of like they get the free reign
but at the same time it is like it's
becoming a little repetitive yeah I
guess I just wish dig a little bit
deeper like something a little bit
different I mean the difference comes in
the fact that the animation itself is so
much of a character and that character
really does shine through here and I I
love anime so for me I'm like this was a
really enjoyable piece of Star Wars
entertainment that is like kind of like
a lot of anime villains behave a kind of
cold-hearted emptiness in the way they
do delivery and sense of like that that
over confidence in it and then a really
aggressive protagonist who's dealing
with anger there's a lot of like good
anime tropes in here and also just Sith
troops yeah Sith tropes but like really
captured in the language of a lot of how
anime I don't want to make it sound like
all anime is the same it's just like
there are some very familiar anime high
quality here I might be super wrong uh
but I got like a lot of like Korean
influence from from this one uh like I
might be just the
I I was just kind of the the vibe that I
I got where it felt a very let's say
very Divergent but it felt a bit
Divergent from like traditional Japanese
anime but again don't quote me on that
uh I'm not an expert I mean it's stuff
like this when they take in when they do
the anime style their minds of things
like ghosts in the Shell or like Cowboy
Bebop uh like or see it steps past
um Space Opera and starts feeling like
genuine sci-fi you know and I thought
that this really that's really captured
that and like yeah the the kinship of
these two I like the wrap around that
they have with that girl I think there's
just so much familiarity but it was
still a really enjoyable piece with some
really Vivid expressive animation again
that's kind of like the the main selling
point of Visions is the uniqueness in in
the the actual physical vision of what
we were watching I think they did a
great job of capturing them to see like
it all done in like a Japanese culture
does feel like a cool like all Universe
yeah can we watch another one please
yeah yeah well Ross still another really
great one man that was still uh super
fun
[Music]
okay okay I see you
have you said Stormtrooper fat
Stormtrooper heavy sets Stormtrooper
spy dancer we missed
[Music]
you is this what I think it is
yeah
it's the form of it
it's a circus what were you thinking
Craig
sits in the house you won't miss A Beat
from here keep your eyes open you guys
okay this is really really pretty
ah yes welcome to Le space Moulin Rouge
let me do more you're not ready yet
don't interfere with the show the show
is pointless how can you still be able
to serve these Invaders it is don't
start we talked about it not the two
different colored eyes I love the French
Resistance Vibes here in World War II
yeah hey
hey it's the French Resistance I'm super
here for this
do these ones even work don't frighten
remember I'll be able to follow every
one of their dirty Imperial steps on my
monitor
I just need to fix our way out that's
all do you really think we have a way
out John yes yes oh my God they're just
gonna blow up everything
those years helping the rebellion and
for what oh come on what we do here will
change the tides but the whole galaxy
you sure
I have to go
should really put that away
wow
[Music]
oh I'm gonna kill them all
facial hair that's not regulation
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh wow the one responsible for her
family's death
[Music]
worse
uh
uh answer baby
[Music]
oh that is messed up
it's all part of the show folks are you
okay take everyone and leave they
thought it was
now look out for John you stay with him
this is now too personal she's about to
go on glorious bastards on this guy that
is on the way with the others
take them up at the
but the egg is going on Louie I have one
last thing to do here
oh my God but this is the only way I can
be free
to call Jordan good job Craig that you
named a Droid right yeah
in territory
looks like Patrick Stewart
oh at the greatest dance of her
life Katniss Everdeen the girl on fire
[Music]
a Droid
oh no she stopped herself you
Rebel scum no it's not him
should have just committed
wow oh
[Music]
holy crap
using silks to take down the empire
nice
oh girls get it done
[Music]
whoa
what
why are you afraid to kill this one guy
no
no it's her son oh is it
you like the eye patch covers the other
eye
you're right you're right good attention
to detail Mikhail
[Music]
how old is she well if it happened at
the beginning it's like a 20 30 year
period who are you
from me I need answers
oh my God take that off
damn she good you go Miss Marvel
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
feels gory
[Music]
about time man 20 years ago the Empire
raided all Village took my son what's
that to do with me he would be your age
why do you hide your true nature ah oh
wow
oh
[Music]
it's okay
oh my god
oh yes it's like Neo and Morpheus some
very strong Frenchman
hope
[Music]
he looks just like me
did he remove his eye you think
yeah I probably did that to just strip
him of any identity to that culture
because I removed his little horns
wow that was a great one yeah
good I love that one a lot of I feel
like with visions a lot of the time the
main takeaway is the animation and like
this some of these disorders have been
really good but most of the time it's
you know you're mainly it's like
animation's amazing yeah and for me I
stopped thinking about the animation and
I was just so hooked into the story uh
and this is the first one out of the six
that we've seen so far though where I
was so pulled into the story and it was
so refreshing and different and haven't
seen something like this in Star Wars
didn't have anything to do with the Jedi
which like I mean I love the Jedi don't
get me wrong point we're like all right
okay yeah I gotta get it light him dork
no it was a beautiful uh just like a
friendly reminder that like you know
French still know it's uh when it comes
to animation uh I is like a big history
nerd and also I feel like Star Wars
pulls so much of its inspiration from
World War II no I loved no no no Rhymes
kids uh I loved the like touching on the
French Resistance and using something
that is so kind of uniquely French to
tell that story yeah
um and in so many ways like that story
has happened so many times in real
history and I don't know there's
something really like that the moment of
the hug just like
ah did something like uh like that's all
it took in order for him to entirely
change the trajectory of his life and I
think that's a beautiful notion yeah I
was saying hug me Greg
no I'm not her father Michael I am not
your father
get away from me Mom Mommy yeah no I
appreciate all the things in riffing on
the historical context where you do feel
like Nazi soldiers are walking to like
uh oh let's go to his entertainment bar
with these like attractive women and who
do a show and stuff let's drink and have
a good time
um but I also loved like some of my
favorite World War II stories are like I
definitely don't know anywhere near as
much as you but the ones I am often test
I mean but it if it were I would lose
and I want you to know that you win here
uh and that's what America's all about
so uh one of my favorite stories that my
favorite kinds of stories are the ones
where or is like um the revolutionists
are working undercover uh you know like
they're in high they're they will be
like at the bars they'll be at the pubs
you know and they can sometimes be
seductive but they're like those they're
those are some like real life Heroes who
pull that off and I think some of
those are the coolest stories to see
that implemented here is neat but then
you had to have that Mother Sun angle
which I feel like should have been way
more predictable for me I totally missed
it you got it I thought it was great I
thought that was it was just so
different than something we've seen in
this world and it's something that I
think is so personal and Primal for
anyone that they can relate to something
I don't know for late but we can all
attach onto or empathize in some way
because we all have parents and whatnot
so uh yeah I thought that was a really
strong one where I I stopped thinking I
don't know it was it was true though the
Visions you usually are like oh the
animation and then for me I'm like
I could not even tell you what the
animation style is yeah now that I'm
thinking about it but the story is going
to stick with me for a long time yeah
that's powerful um yeah because he
doesn't even end in a way where you're
like
it could go either way where he he could
not believe her or he could believe her
and I like that it doesn't end in a
definitive way that's open to
interpretation of how the path that
might go down you know but it ends on a
hopeful note yeah
and it's all about Hope Greg it's what
Star Wars is all about Hope and people
learning about the force and light and
dark that's what I did
that's what it is
um but yeah that
maybe not on an animation level is my
favorite one but from the story levels
this is this is when I feel like I truly
will not forget out of out of all the
Star Wars ones oh I think the best way
to gauge a story like this is if you
took the Star Wars out of it would it
still be a good story and it is and this
one absolutely I mean I could just very
easily reimagine this as like a Noir
French film uh during World War II and
it would be just as impactful to be like
oh crap just a little kid that was
stolen from the village in also Lorraine
uh yeah yeah that's cool that was really
cool I was really really impressed with
that one
I was really impressed with that one
um yeah I love that one what did you
guys think what was it what was your
favorite their opinion I love their
opinion screw everyone's opinions are
that are not ours we don't even know
what you think but YouTube does tell us
what you think yeah for algorithm
purposes algorithm engagement and
yeah
I think I don't care I don't give a
Greg hates French people especially the
French no this is just like I love like
I know their culture is not like at the
Pinnacle that it once was but every once
in a while I'm like oh yeah that's why
that's why they were the ones that like
made our industry
the Jews did
you know it's interesting you say that
let's cut let's get in this video okay
[Music]